єврокомісія рекомендувала на дату
україні безвізовий режим калі українцям
і захоплення на скачування ваги ще може
виконати процес проведення
безвізового режиму за раз технічних річки
їх небудь передумав для того, щоб мета
безвізовий режим нам не було на дону
я завалений бачу безумовно будуть на
правду країни члени та ж українці в
європарламент recall і буду дискусія в
європейському наполегливому викурі 100 ватів і на
магате si nu heel цю ситуацію до цього
рішення про сухих сина лірики мітрій моїм
з європейського союзу ми все-таки
сподіваємося що так я думаю що кольором до
кінця літа ті рішення малі будуть і
прийняті віра в європейському союзі студит
технічно у вас і немає рішення винна
була почата проти від поні ванна зону
вільно торгівлі з'їсть почи ладить і жаху
член у team за дикими позиції українські
експортери вже вичерпали aussi квоти на
біс митна експорт своєї продукції в с
ви будете парку але ти їздиш іти круті
кондером підемо дістати не позиціями там
не помаду і причин вбирання вже по м'ясу
курки його такі по виноградному
яблучному соку пуншем пузо цим вже
вокаліст вони квоти
а в особі не означає що не продовжується
постачання до Європейського союзу ними
компанія маяки
маю таким можна вести з України на адже
нам би змити на ній основі тату
триває і обсі ірина боготу більше
не їжте квоти столітті в нас є з правді ми
б тут і комплексно ріс мова за
європейським союзом листопад ключ але прохід
і jacques по зайти повз нього просто
пробувати та лібералізувати їж вище та
нижче ванни закладання на прикладі
йде за і віце-прем'єри форма
державного апарату та курди ну і ти
продала суті вас добрими спину
hipster
диким я план подуло не базар убити тебе
в результаті cisco раджів настою такий
ембід no-till
вона стратегію реформування навіть наука
управління в рамках та до мого перед
бачатою як ми будемо у
ширяли до тієї функцією aqua міністерств
як ми будемо передавати німці скажемо з
міністерстві на місці
вікі-віки будуть структури міністерств я
поважаю я собою 100 позиції що ці люди
і кіно даний момент єна державний
службі он і через конкурс барани будуть
основними претендентами
знайти посади з новим функцію але
функціоналом через
виду світло через свої знання через свої
разу мене там галодить їй enjoy it розуму
говорить та продам скручування масова
кит вже сьогодні мало б у дар і типу за
всім державним службу у team я зрадив
віконне поспішала реформа дір служби на
гранту автоматично успіх оборот без
корупцію ким чен нам тут не мотається
контроль запиту зростати робота державних
рівня влади і в ряді міністерств і
відомств із таки йдуть дістати широке
завдання вирізане тальне завдання mesh
видом через завдання еге мало б нам за
без підрахунку доступ до розуміння того
як порада буваєте в державній машині на
і вигляд видно з менше їх мови
деякі може створі ось і кори харчування
фактор і ноту через дрезден механізми
через електронне в ряду вання через
розарії процедури відразу милі процедури
на дому саму розумі ти що проти
системи
він значний і точно чим більше ми
будемо озаглавлювати
у реформуванні вин будеш признач
нижчою за і віце прем'єр України не
завжди свою приватну коновалів виклику
адже його жили в пливу травня
віце-прем'єр землю
інтеграції щуку не батіг і прикладом
пробуксовує і баштових для україни хп
равликових груп її син реформ від того ж ви
вигляд вивідає через результат моєї душі
розруху і що c
упр лімітів вони все ближче нести їх
інструменті вікія без посередника при
guerra їв льодовий офіс європейської
інтеграції та заступники міністри до
євроінтеграції за ким та беккі мати такі
подвиги на 5 порядку ваней своїм
міністрам та віце-прем'єру євроінтеграції
через yast одягаюсь і створення у
рядового комітету рішення проекту
моєму прийняті на плечі му засідання
ряду поза ціни інструментом я навіть
середня розруха ви на допомогу в
романську вас встиг у тому щоб ми
все-таки розум руколою акіхіро чайки
може викликати та серйозні спрути я не
думаю що заводу простий процес я
сприймаю c наївно а led par ікона наш
що ж vb6 випадки в нас вдасться
вийти на рішення через те, що ти рішення
он і за вимоги нашим сусп рст вам
який він повинен таку